يرمي طرف النزاع بثقلهما العسكري في بخموت
فيشتد الدمار ويتاجل الحسم لكن القوات
الروسيه كما الاوكرانيه لا تكف عن اعلان
انتصاراتها في المدينه المنكوبه ومحيطها
وفي سائر منطقه دومباس شرقيه اوكرانيا
مالك شركه فاغنر يفغيني قال ان قواته
تقدمت في بخموت مسافه نصف كيلو متر ولم
يبقى تحت سيطره الاوكرانيين سوى كيلومتر
مربع ونصف الكيلومتر خلافا لذلك اكدت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان قوات
بلادها تواصل تقدمها في اتجاه ضواحي بخموت
بعد ان تمكنت من السيطره على اكثر من عشره
مواقع للروس في الضواحي الشماليه
والجنوبيه من المدينه واسري عدد من الجنود
الروس
في خضم تلك البيانات المتضاربه ثم ما هو
مؤكد ففي اعلان منذ شنها الحرب اعلنت
موسكو الاحد مقتل قائدين عسكريين من جيشها
على الجبهه احدهما هو قائد اللواء الرابع
للبنادق الاليه اما الثاني فهو نائب قائد
فيلق الجيش
والمسؤول عن العمل العسكري والسياسي ويعكس
هذا الاعلان احتدام القتال في الايام
الاخيره في وقت تؤكد فيه موسكو انها صدت
هجوما اوكرانيا على جبهه بطول نحو 100
كيلومتر شرقيه اوكرانيا لا يعرف ما اذا
كان ذلك هو بدايه هجوم كييفل مضاد لكن مما
لا شك فيه هو ان الرئيس الاوكراني بدا
الحشد لذلك الهجوم الواسع من اجل استعاده
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الروس لا سيما
في الشرق ها هو في برلين يحقق اختراقا في
جدار التردد الالماني بش دعم مجهود بلاده
الحربي
نحن لا نخفف دعمنا لقد قررنا للتو تنفيذ
خطه مساعدات عسكريه جديده تبلغ قيمتها
ملياران و700 مليون يورو ستتلقى القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه المزيد من دبابات
مشاه ماردر وانظمه
التحفظ برلين على طلبات كييف من الطائره
الحربيه فقد بدا زيلينسكي راضيا عن الدعم
الالماني الذي اصبح ثانيا بعد الدعم
الامريكي
حان الوقت لكي نحدد نهايه هذه الحرب هذا
العام يمكننا ان نجعل هزيمه المعتدي لا
رجعه فيها وانا ممتن لاكبر مساعده عسكريه
تلقيناها منذ بدايه الغزو الروسي هذا دعم
قوي شكرا جزيلا لك اولاف
ومنذ بدء روسيا الحرب على اوكرانيا قبل
نحو 15 شهرا قدمت المانيا مساعدات لكييف
بقيمه 17 مليار يورو
الحفاوه الرسميه التي حظي بها في المانيا
شملت منحه جائزه تشرمان تقديرا لما سمي
خدمات اوكرانيا من اجل وحده اوروبا كما
واكب الزياره احتفاء بها في الشارع حيث
خرج مئات الالمان في مسيره حاشده حملوا
على ما اوكرانيا وردد هتافات داعمه لها
ولصمودها في الحرب